Long before Al Capone turned his eye to bootlegging and well before Bugsy Siegel
decided to take his, I got Gaines and cash in on the casino. Boom, in Vegas,
there was another boss in town.
This one was perhaps the most unassuming of ladies.
And within just a few years of setting foot on American soul for the first time
she had built up one of the largest organized crime empires at the still new
nation had ever seen.
When the papers talked about her and they talked about her a lot.
They called her mother man. One. Why? Well, as she once said herself,
I am ma because I give them what a mother cannot sometimes give money and horses
and diamonds. And she took care of her children,
a vast network of criminals from all walks of, of life.
And with all kinds of specialities, she guided them, trained them.
And when it was necessary, she protected them as only a mother could.
Her story starts in the middle of the 19th century.
When people were coming from all across Europe to find a new life in the land of
opportunity and promise, some were looking for a fresh start.
Some were trying to escape the dire conditions of their homelands and others
were just looking for adventure.
What they found went,
they got to America was often a bit of a far cry from what they had imagined.
Fika Mandelbaum and her husband Wolf Israel were just two of the hundreds of
thousands of immigrants who poured into New York city in the mid 18 hundreds
sources barriers to the exact date,
but suggest that they left Europe around 1848 and settled in an area of New York
cities, lower east side, known as little Germany. It wasn't a great place,
but was a place where like-minded and undoubtedly adventurous individuals could
find others who shared a history, a culture and struggles.
And there were a lot of struggles.
The typical tenements apartment was Amere 325 feet and most to a home,
to as many as 15 people live in America.
It wasn't as much about living as it was about survival.
And in order to survive Mandel bomb and her husband spent their days up to 14
hours at a time as street pedals.
This wasn't an entirely new way of life for them.
You see Mandel bomb was from one of the hands of Jewish families living in the
German state of HES castle. And they weren't just a minority.
They existed on the outskirts of more mainstream society, Jewish,
Jewish families,
like hers were often assaulted and extorted forced to remain on the move for
their own safety,
especially if they didn't pay the protection money that thugs often demanded in
exchange for simply leaving them alone.
It's likely her father made a living as a merchant and a P buying and selling
secondhand goods to support his family.
But this is only speculation for the early years of their marriage.
She and her husbands lived the lives of wandering peds as well.
This was a hard life and one where they could expect to earn only about $6 a
week.
In August, 1857, a massive hurricane sunk ship called the central America.
It had been carrying a huge amount of gold. And without that gold,
the economy also started to sink.
It was a huge deal and caused a major financial panic as businesses,
large and small start to fail investments crashed and people realized they were
suddenly facing unemployment and ruin in,
but something else happened to desperate times called for desperate measures and
with more and more people facing empty kitchens and even empty of bellies,
crime rose a lot, a surge of children took to the streets,
often sent there by destitute parents, desperate to find something,
to feed their families little lands.
They were perfect for picking pockets and stealing, whatever wasn nailed down.
And even in the face of economic ruin,
there were lots of opportunities for most enterprising young scavengers children
took to the dirty litted streets of the city to find anything that might help
them make life a little more bearable,
a bit of cotton that fell from a bale flower and sugar callously spilled onto
the street and general junk.
That was just lying around the place. Sometimes these things,
they were dropped and discarded.
Sometimes they were stolen and all of those thieves,
they needed a place to sell their stolen goods. I mean,
you can't eat jewelry after all and mother Mendel bomb.
She saw a Brill business opportunity forging ahead,
without any real help from her husband who police would lay note was a non
entity. Mandelbaum started buying and selling what those scavengers found.
And she also started buying from the female pick pockets and thieves that made
their living knicking stuff from some of the high end department stores that
still catered to the city's wealthy mother.
Mandelbaum had a few things going for Herrin.
One of those things was her experience, not just buying and selling,
but haggling on prices. When she bought,
she offered about a fifth of what she thought she could sell the item for.
And given that peds averaged only a few dollars a week at the time selling the
standard sort of fair.
The markup that came with branching out into stolen goods gave her a serious
boost in income,
and she made the most of it eight years after the crash Mander bump had built up
the cash and connections to be able to lease a building that contained dry good
store rent was steep and adjusted for inflation.
She paid and estimated six thousand one hundred and six thousand five hundred
for a first and second year there that's certainly a lot more than a Pless
salary would've realistically supported.
So clearly there was something fishy going on, but this was 19th century.
New Yorkers look thing. The other way was sort of a way of life.
The store was indeed just the front of her operation and it wasn't long before
she was dealing in everything from jewels,
particularly diamonds to fine silk and lace silver gold,
and even horses and carriages once she even bought and resold and entire herd of
goats, because well, if it made money, she was in,
she was excellent at hiding what she was doing as well,
employing other German immigrants and listing them as salespeople on her census
records.
And technically that was kind of true.
It wasn't just merchandise lifted off the streets of New York that found us way
into our warehouses either when the great Chicago fast swept through the city in
1871,
there was unsurprisingly a ton of looting and pillaging going on there.
A lot of what was stolen,
ended up passing through her hands into her warehouses.
And it was all adding to her bottom line.
If mother mens Obama had simply been fence,
just someone who only bought and sold stolen goods for a considerable profit,
the story might have ended there,
but she wasn't just buying and selling stolen goods.
She built up a massive network of connections that stretched across the country
and well up into Canada,
even as she took more and more little pick pockets on under her wing,
she would also turn around and greet cops and judges,
particularly the ones that had a loose interpretation of the law with a friendly
smile,
even local politicians knew how popular she was and they were sure to keep an
eye good side.
There was some serious bribery going on there as you might expect.
And let's be completely honest at the time New York city was filled with just as
much corruption as it was cockroaches.
It was a time when the city was under the watchful eye of the notoriously
crooked politicians of Taney hole.
The entity behind the 1850s city council nicknamed the 40 thieves by the time
mother Mandel bomb's operation was in full swing boss.
Tweed was in charge given that he was known for working in an office that he
opened sole to have an official place to take payments.
It's safe to say he was fine with all kinds of unlawful shenanigans.
TA hall in particular was well aware of her operation and made it a point to
keep on mother Mendel. Bomb's good side. She couldn't vote.
That's true,
but she was rapidly becoming very influential and she knew plenty of people who
could vote one hand washes.
The other ends Manor bomb Zem empire continued to grow while Tweed was quite
literally given the keys to the city's treasury in 1870 and started expanding
his own criminal enterprises.
Tweeted is a politician that history remembers as being one of the most corrupt
politicians do ever rise to power in the city,
a New York state Senator with a list of other titles and positions,
a mile long Tweed used his political clout to swindle and steal and
unthinkable amounts of money from the city's C as a whole,
which would in today's money amounts were around 3.5 billion
in ill Goding gains.
His Taman hall was a powerful ally for mother Mandel bomb to half.
Meanwhile Mandel bomb started hiring more than just a few hungry street
searches. That was only so far.
They were going to be able to take her after all and acquiring the loot was only
half the job she had to get rid of it too.
And so she started building a team of associates to LA her merchandise in
Gravers,
who could remove identifying marks from jewelry were taken into a confidence
cab.
Drivers were kept on calling in case someone needed to make a fast escape and
partner at a major law firm.
How and Hubble were kept on retainer just in case she even had a special funds
for her most trusted associates and called it.
Perhaps the most honest name she could have used the bureau for the protection
of criminals, the face of the city, it was changing.
And mother Mandelbaum was there to take advantage of it every step of the way.
Sure.
Mother Mandel bomb increased her wealth exponentially when she branched out into
selling stolen goods, but she didn't stop there.
She was an entrepreneur and entrepreneurs are always looking for the next big
thing for her.
It was bankrolling other criminal enterprises undertaken by some of the most
audacious criminals in her little black book of names.
You got to spend money to make money. The old saying goes,
and that's even true of crime.
The countless immigrants who moved the young New York city helped build it on
the shoulders of talents brought from the old world and German immigrants. The,
a excelled adding engraving from wood cuts and prints. It was just a short hop,
skip, and a jump into counterfeiting.
And that was just one aspect of her organization.
Even as our own finances continued to climb,
she made it clear that if someone had a great plan and even better skills,
she was willing to bank roll jobs that would turn a profit.
She was connected to some of the biggest bank robbers at the timing,
including people like Wesley Allen and Michael Kutz.
She also had provided these startup funds for a job that would turn into one of
the biggest robberies of them, all a known associate of George Leon honors.
Leslie.
She provided him with around $65,000 in today's money to get the people and
tools needed to Rob the Manhattan savings bank in 1878. And Robert,
he did netting $2,747,700 from the
bank frequented by people with names like Rockefeller, Vanderbilt, and Carnegie.
To put that in perspective,
we need to adjust for inflation today that one score would be worth around
72 million give or take.
There was a certain sort of Symbio to the whole setup without mother Mandel
bomb.
The city's thieves and pick pockets would have nowhere to launder their stolen
goods. And without her ring of thieves,
Mandel bomb wouldn't have had a steady flow of goods to buy markup and flip.
It's no wonder she wanted to take care of them.
And in order to make sure her thieves were the very best they could be.
Legend says she opens Mandel barns, grand street school in 1870.
It's an unassuming name perhaps,
but anyone who walked through the doors of the storefront on Clintons and grand
street was walking into a school designed to give the city street children,
some valuable life lessons,
the sort that involved checking your morals at the door. And there weres.
You have children who needed to learn if they were going to survive.
As the city was teaming with orphan children who were known to the more
fortunate street rats,
the school started with the basic and kids were taught criminal life skills,
like pick pocketing and the art of misdirection while there's no official
transcripts from the school, which isn't exactly surprising.
It's believed that Mandel bomb recruited some of the cities,
finest adult thieves and con men to teach the children criminal skills.
Those that showed and innate talents were taught. Other things,
blackmail the art of the con burglary and even safe cracking and Mansor bomb
recruited the best of the best to come and to work for her directly,
including one young woman who had become known as the princess of crime. Sophie,
Lance was one of Mandel bomb's star students.
And after getting her star learning from her pick pocket parents,
then being taken under mother's wing,
Lance became notorious as a con artist and a thief who ran some seriously brazen
scams.
One of her favorites was reportedly using a feminine WIS to lure men into a
hotel room, sweet talk them out of their clothes, and then blackmail them.
Lions eventually gave up a life of crime and condemned Mandel bomb for taking
advantage of the lonely, hungry and desperate setting them on a path of crime.
They may never have gone down. Otherwise that's certainly one way to look at it,
but not everyone was quite so critical. In fact,
most people had the opposite view of their matron league crime Lord as for the
school that was fairly short lived, Vanda bomb,
shut it down herself in 1876 after only six years.
So why shut down something so successful?
Well that's because she got wind of a new student who had enrolled and she was
too smart to let the son of a police officer in on a secrets.
Mother Mendel bomb's massive crime empire.
It spans from the lowliest pick pockets to the upper echelons of New York.
City's political landscape. No one can be at work all the time though.
And when Mendel bomb wasn't dealing in stolen jewels, uh, herds of goats,
she was far from frightening. She didn't pro the streets with a gun,
just looking for trouble. She didn't rule her neighborhood with an iron fist.
And in fact, by all accounts,
she was rather nice when her obituary ran in the German language paper,
the New York VO Zong, it described her as honorable and reliable.
And as someone whose word was as good as gold when New York city's law
enforcement was asked about her character police, chief,
George w whaling described her this way as a woman and a mother,
she has spoken of with respect, others spoke of her as a wonderful woman,
a woman of ability and nerve and laud her for a generosity.
It wasn't just a generosity. People spoke highly of though.
It was also her parties.
At the same time she was buying in the selling and dealing mans.
One was living in a house on the lower east side where she held sus and sent out
invitations from the honorable and Mrs. William Mandelbaum,
the parties were sometimes elegant, formal affairs,
sometimes summertime picnics, but they were always exciting.
The guest lists would include all of new York's most prominent judges and
politicians along with some of her criminal empire,
it would allow business acquaintances to rub elbows,
schmooze over cocktails and ultimately of their own movement upwards through the
hierarchy of crime.
And that was fine with her at any rate,
aside from the whole criminal empire thing,
mother Mandel bomb was almost shockingly conventional.
She was a generous and respected member of her synagogue.
She invited a associates into her home to visit with her children.
And when those in her organization needed help, she provided it.
And that's likely one of the things that allowed her to stay business for quite
so long. When it came to dealing with those in her own community,
she was known for offering jobs when they were needed. And even undercuting,
the prices offered by legitimate wholesalers and giving,
struggling families the help they badly needed.
When it came time for law enforcement to bring her down,
they knew they were on their own how close-knit community,
they would not betray her.
So's a question, where's the police in all of this. Sure.
Bribery can get you somewhere,
but it just takes one person not willing to take some cash and look the other
where a,
to bring it all tumbling down New York city's police department was fairly new
at the time and they didn't quite figured out what their role was in the growing
city. When they were on the streets, they were looking for some specific things,
gang related, brawls drunk and disorderly disruptions,
and the vocal troublesome crowds that tended to congregate when social reformers
in the, like got a little too preachy on their soap boxes.
When it came to Mandelbaum,
she was parked firmly in the blind spot of a police department who would only
negotiate for the return of stolen goods if the victim paid them to do so.
And this was unofficial policy, not just some corrupt cop,
doing some shady stuff to see what they could fill their pockets with.
Since it was sometimes easier for victims,
just to forget about what that lost thieves and fences dealing in stolen goods
knew they weren't a high priority still it's wildly impressive that mother
Mandel managed to stay out of any real and serious trouble for around 30 years.
Okay. So what was it that finally brought down her criminal empire? Well,
it was a bolt of silk and the Pinkerton detective agency.
It wasn't until 1884 that a New York district attorney named Peter Olson had
finally had enough of the queen of fences and turned to the Pinkertons for help.
They sent detective Gustav, Frank, who got an introduction through someone,
perhaps not as loyal as Mandel bomb had thought.
When police finally raided a warehouse,
they found silk that the undercover Pinkerton had sold her and a ton of other
stolen merchandise. So anyway, we're wondering, well, what exactly is a ton,
how much stolen loo was the there on contemporary journalists wrote it did not
seem possible that so much wealth could be assembled in one spot.
There seemed to be enough clothes to supply an army.
There were trunks filled with precious gems and silverware.
Antique furniture was stacked against a wall and keep in mind that this is at a
time when children were playing in the streets alongside the decomposing remains
of carriage horses, which were just left, where they had fallen.
And when many parents weren't sure how they were going to feed their families,
most wouldn't have been able to envision holding a single earring much less,
be able to imagine a whole suitcase of precious jewels.
That should have been enough there to put her away for a long time.
But remarkably, that didn't happen. Manda bomb her son.
And so Clark insisted that they were simply running a dry good store,
which technically was almost true. She claimed she had never stolen anything,
which again, well, you've kind of got to give that to her in all her career.
She really never did steal anything herself. Amanda bomb was let out on bail,
which she promptly jumped and headed north into Canada.
And the story is still not done. 10 years later,
Mandelbaum had set herself up as a respectable sort of citizen living in
Hamilton, Ontario,
working in a hat shop and participating in the local Hebrew congregation.
But is there any more to the story than that possibly at any rate by 1894,
she had found herself pining for her old stomping grounds in the 13th ward.
She made that known too telling friends and acquaintances just as much then in
February of that year and bomb passed away.
A coffin was headed from Ontario to New York city, but here's the thing.
No one really knew if it was actually her body or just one more brilliant cog in
the well old machine that had allowed her to stay a free woman for so long.
Did she fake her death? So she could return to a beloved city in peace.
People thought she might have,
was she now calling herself Madam fus and returning to her roots as a simple
paddler it's entirely possible.
No one ever really knew just as no one knows how much money she handled in her
lifetime estimates vary with one suggesting that when she fled at New York in
1884, she left behind merchandise that in today's money would be worth around
24 million give or take.
So I really hope you found that video. Interesting. If you did,
please do smash that light button below and don't forget to subscribe.
We got multiple videos like this every single week. So when you subscribe,
hit that bell icon, you will find out when we put out those new you videos.
So please do that. Also.
Why not check out some videos from the archive that are linked to on the screen
and as always, thank you for watching.